ces derniers temps on entend beaucoup
parler de l'intelligence artificielle et
des nombreuses menaces qu'elles
pourraient représenter l'une d'elles
c'est le fait que l'ia comme on
l'appelle pourrait faire disparaître un
grand nombre de métiers
c'est vrai que grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle les machines semblent être
capable de faire de plus en plus de
choses et pourtant quand on pense à ce
qu'un ordinateur fait mieux que les
humains il s'agit en général de trucs
assez bourrin faire des gros calculs
manipuler des tableaux de données
énormes des choses que l'on saurait
faire nous-mêmes mais que les machines
font simplement beaucoup beaucoup plus
vite que nous mais à la fin ils font
rien que nous imiter elle ne crée rien
nouveau d'ailleurs la créativité qu'elle
soit artistique ou scientifique semble
bien être un domaine qui reste l'apanage
du cerveau humain est pourtant
aujourd'hui on va voir que de plus en
plus les machines savent se montrait
créative et qu'elle pourrait bien un
jour être meilleur que nous pour
inventer et créer et on va le voir
spécifiquement dans le domaine du jeu
[Musique]
depuis presque les débuts de
l'informatique et l'invention du concept
d'intelligence artificielle dans les
années 50 on a essayé d'utiliser le jeu
comme un moyen de comparer
l'intelligence humaine et l'intelligence
artificielle et notamment le jeu
d'échecs
considérée comme une des activités les
plus intelligentes pratiqué par notre
espèce d'ailleurs l'idée d'une machine
jouant aux échecs fascine depuis encore
plus longtemps puisqu'à la fin du xviiie
siècle un inventeur hongrois wolfgang
von kamp allen avait fait le tour des
cours d'europe avec un automate surnommé
le turc mécanique il avait l'apparence
d'un humain vêtu à la turque fixé sur un
petit meuble muni d'un plateau des
chèques et cet automate était capable de
jouer une partie d'échec contre un
humain et même le plus souvent de le
battre le tueur que mécanique aurait
ainsi affronter de nombreux souverains
de l'époque comme napoléon bonaparte
catherine ii de russie où frédéric ii de
prusse
alors évidemment comme vous vous en
doutez il y avait un truc
en fait le meuble avait une cavité qui
permettait à une personne suffisamment
petit de se cacher et de jouer la partie
en actionnant l'automate donc pas du
tout d'intelligence artificielle là
dedans mais dès la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale les pères de
l'informatique comme alan turing ont
commencé à imaginer des algorithmes
capables de jouer aux échecs et les
premières implémentations ont été faites
dans les années 50
quelques années plus tard à noël 1976 on
pouvait même se faire offrir sous le
sapin
le premier programme d'échec commercial
appelé my crochet ce qui était vendu sur
l'ordinateur kim wan une bête de course
royalement munis de inca de mémoire peu
à peu les programmes sont devenus bien
sûr de plus en plus forts grâce à la
progression de la puissance des machines
et le tournant l'histoire vous ne
connaissez certainement en 1997
l'ordinateur d'ibm blood ibm a battu le
meilleur joueur du monde garry kasparov
4 à 2 sur un affrontement en six parties
à l'époque certains avaient vu cette
victoire comme le moment de l'histoire
humaine où les machines prenait
symboliquement le pouvoir sur les
humains la défaite de notre espèce est
son merveilleux cerveau et pourtant est
ce qu'on peut dire que deep blue était
une machine intelligente voir créative
eh bien à mon avis c'était surtout un
monstre de puissance bourrine d'ailleurs
on dit bien que cette bible ou à une
machine à nordine
auteur qui a gagné pas un programme ou
un algorithme juste un gros tas de
transistors ce qui soit dit en passant a
évidemment été une super opération de
communication pour ibm
mais dans le fond dit blues jouent de
façon pas très fine et pas franchement
intelligente qui ressemble un peu à la
façon dont moi je joue je vous cache pas
que je n'aime pas du tout joué aux
échecs et je joue d'une façon assez
stupide et fatigante qui consiste à
regarder absolument tous les coups
possibles et à chercher le meilleur un
moment typique d'une partie d'échecs
il y a en moyenne une vingtaine de coups
possibles à considérer on peut s'amuser
à représenter sa sous forme d'un arbre
est évidemment pour déterminer le
meilleur bas il suffit pas de regarder
ces coups là mais aussi les réponses que
l'adversaire peut y apporter
et si l'adversaire a aussi disons 20
réponses possibles eh bien ça fait un
total de 400 possibilité à examiner et
c'est pour ça que je trouve ça fatigant
évidemment si c'est un ordinateur qui
réfléchit plutôt que moi eh bien il peut
s'amuser à regarder aussi le coup
d'après est encore celui d'après et
ainsi de suite en anticipant comme ça
plusieurs coups à l avance sauf qu'à
chaque fois on multiplie par 20 les
possibilités et l'arbre croît de façon
exponentielle alors dit blue était
justement une machine énorme dans
l'architecturé était particulièrement
optimisé pour évaluer des coûts de cette
façon ce qui lui permettait de tester
200 millions de coûts à chaque seconde
et c'est comme ça qu'elle pouvait
anticiper jusqu'à une douzaine de coups
à l'avancé dans la partie dans ce que je
viens de vous décrire et manquant même
un ingrédient pour que la machine puisse
jouer aux échecs de façon efficace
c'est bien de regarder des milliards de
coût mais comment on choisit le meilleur
il faut une manière de les comparer un
et de décider entre toutes les
possibilités
laquelle est la plus intéressante c'est
ce qu'on appelle une fonction
d'évaluations une fonction d'évaluations
c'est une manière d'attribuer une valeur
à une certaine situation sur le plateau
ce qu'on appelle une position de façon à
pouvoir comparer différentes positions
et choisir la plus avantageuse si vous
jouez un peu aux échecs vous savez sans
doute qu'il existe une manière d'évaluer
très simple qu'on enseigne généralement
aux débutants on attribue des valeurs
fictive aux pièces restantes sur le
plateau un point pour un pion 3 pour un
cavalier ou un fou 5 pour une tour et 9
pour la dame
attention ces valeurs sont artificielles
inconventionnelle elles ne servent pas à
calculer le score dans la partie mais
elles permettent en gros d'estimer la
force d'une situation et de décider si
un mouvement peut être un terreau
sans par exemple si vous capturez un
pion avec un cavalier qui se fait manger
derrière et bien vous gagnez un point
mais vous en perdez 3 donc c'est une
mauvaise idée
si en revanche vous capturez une tour
avec un fou qui se fait manger ensuite
et bien au total vous gagnez deux points
plutôt une bonne idée
cette fonction d'évaluation très basique
permet de mieux choisir ses coûts et
d'éviter les sacrifices idiot alors
évidemment ça fait pas tout parce que la
localisation des pièces sur le plateau
est évidemment essentiel le fait de
menacer le roi adverse ou de protéger le
sien tout ça la fonction d'évaluation
utilisée par deep blue était évidemment
plus compliqué que de simplement compter
les points mais elle avait été conçue à
la main par des joueurs très
expérimentés pour prendre en compte
l'ensemble des critères qu'ils avaient
imaginé
en résumé on peut pas dire que deep blue
était franchement intelligente et encore
moins créative la machine faisait des
milliards de calculs bourrin et prenait
des décisions grâce à des critères
établis par des humains juste un gros
tas de muscles virtuel en somme un on
était à mon avis assez loin de la
défaite de l'intelligence humaine
[Musique]
alors ça c'était les échecs et ça date
d'il ya plus de vingt ans maintenant
mais il y a quelques années vous n'avez
pas pu y échapper il y a eu une autre
petite révolution dans le domaine la
même histoire a eu lieu avec le jeu de
go en apparence le goût peut sembler
être un jeu comparable aux échecs on a
un plateau il ya deux joueurs les noirs
et les blancs qui jouent à tour de rôle
en posant des pièces qu'on appelle des
pierres ça a même l'air encore plus
simple que les échecs puisqu'il n'ya
qu'un seul type de pierre le principe du
jeu est le suivant à son tour chaque
joueur dépose une pierre sur une des
intersections la grille qui fait 19 par
19 et les pierres restent là ne se
déplace pas et on marque des points en
capturant des pierres adverses et en
contrôlant des territoires par
encerclement voyez par exemple ici un
plateau en fin de partie avec les
territoires capturés par les noirs et
les blancs et ici le joueur blanc à
gagner d'un seul point alors tu t'y 20
ans on pourrait s'imaginer que deep blue
et sa stratégie bourrine pourrait très
bien marché aussi pour le goût est en
fait non ça ne marche pas du tout une
des raisons c'est la taille du plateau
je vous ai dit que la grille faisait 19
par 19 il ya donc trois cent soixante et
une intersection en tout début de partie
ça fait donc trois cent soixante et un
coût possible
évidemment quand la partie progresse ça
se réduit mais en moyenne ça va être
autour de 250 à 300 choix possibles à
chaque coup si on prend la route des
possibilités que j'avais dessiné pour
les échecs on avait vingt coups
possibles à chaque tour et donc 400
coups à examiner si on inclut la réponse
de l'adversaire ici on en est à trois
cents coups et donc presque cent mille
possibilités avec la réponse est comme
ça croît de façon exponentielle pour
appliquer cette stratégie de recherche
avec ne serait ce que quelques coups d'
avance on se retrouve à devoir
considérer des milliards de milliards de
cas l'autre difficulté c'est la fonction
d'évaluation je vous ai dit qu aux
échecs qu'on arrive à estimer
numériquement la force d'une position et
à faire des choix entre différentes
possibilités aux gosses est beaucoup
plus difficile en cours de partie c'est
extrêmement compliqué de juger de façon
objective qui est en train de gagner et
donc de décider si une position est
meilleure qu'une autre
on dit d'ailleurs que les bons joueurs
de goût une vision assez intuitive
organique de ce genre de choses
ils sentent les forces sur le plateau
mais il ne calcule pas un score comme on
pourrait le faire aux échecs
les conséquences de ces deux différences
le nombre de coups possibles et la
difficulté de l'évaluation font qu'il ya
une dizaine d'années
les meilleurs programmes de goût était
complètement incapable de rivaliser avec
de bons joueurs humains et on imaginait
que ça prendrait encore plusieurs
décennies avant que l'on vive avec le
goût la même chose que ce qu'on avait
connu avec la victoire de deep blue sur
kasparov et pourtant vous le savez sans
doute en 2016 le programme alpha go de
google dit mind a battu le meilleur
joueur du monde unix et dole quatre
victoires à une
pour réaliser cet exploit alfano a
utilisé une méthode bien différente
basée sur un domaine de l'intelligence
artificielle qu'on appelle le machine
learning parfois traduits en français
comme apprentissage automatique ou
apprentissage statistiques
l'idée est d'apprendre à un algorithme à
faire quelque chose à partir d'une
grande quantité de données qui lui
servent d'exemple j'avais déjà expliqué
ces notions dans ma vidéo sur le dip
learning et je vous y renvoie si vous
êtes intéressés pour s'entraîner
l'algorithme alpha go à utiliser une
base de données de 160000 parties toutes
jouées par des grands maîtres du go ça
représente au total plus de 30 millions
de coûts alpha go et est constitué de
deux réseaux de neurones
l'un avait pour mission de choisir les
bonnes branches de l'arbre des
possibilités pour éviter d'avoir à
explorer une quantité invraisemblable de
coups et l'autre étaient chargés
d'évaluer les positions explorer en leur
attribuant un score une valeur qui
représentait en gros la probabilité
estimée de gagner la partie à partir de
là et c'est au moyen de ces deux
algorithmes de deep learning khalfa go a
pu réaliser l'exploit de battre lycée
dole alors est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'elle fallou était plus intelligent
plus créatifs et - bouygues ou alors
peut-être mais dans le fond vous voyez
que pour que ça fonctionne
il a fallu disposer de la base de
données des parties jouées par les
grands maîtres alpha go a appris en
étudiant la façon de jouer des meilleurs
joueurs de tous les temps
alors certes il a battu lycée d'olmes et
peut-être simplement en imitant tous les
grands joueurs alpha gonnard ya créé
nouveau enfin c'est ce qu'on a envie de
penser mais c'est peut-être pas si sûr
et pour l'illustrer je voudrais vous
montrer le moment le plus dingue de cet
affrontement
il s'agit du 37e coup de la seconde
partie la petite description la
situation 1
vous avez donc lycée dole ici à droite
et en face de lui un anonyme dont le
travail est simplement de jouer sur le
plateau les coups que lui dicte de la
machine la scène que l'on va regarder
représente que l'on voit aussi parfois
dans des championnats l'échec
vous avez deux commentateurs dans une
autre salle qui reproduisent les coûts
sur un grand tableau et les commentent
en
tran les stratégies possibles le
commentateur assis à droite n'est pas
n'importe qui c'est michael reynolds un
joueur de go professionnels d'ailleurs
le seul joueur occidental à avoir
atteint le grade 2 9e dan et regarder ce
qui va se passer
alpha goa les noirs il vient de jouer on
voit le coup sûr le vrai plateau ici
mais les commentateurs n'ont pas encore
vu ce coup et ils vont le découvrir
observer la scène je vous ai traduit
quelques éléments du dialogue elle
dessert soit on dirait que les
commentateurs but complètement tout ce
qui vient de se passer c'est call fagots
à jouer un coup totalement inattendue
qui en principe devrait être considéré
comme une erreur de débutant
et d'ailleurs on voit la réaction du
commentateur d'abord il pense simplement
qu'il a mal vous coup et il le place à
côté
ensuite ils semblent se dire qu'alpha
goa bouquet a fait une grosse erreur et
peu à peu on dirait qu'ils voient
l'intérêt du coup mais sans être
complètement sûr et pourtant ce qui aura
une influence essentielles sur la fin de
la partie dans un autre coin du plateau
alors la vidéo qu'on vient de voir
suggère que lycée doll est sorti quand
il a vu ce coup en fait non il était
sorti avant pour fumer il avait le droit
et d'autres images montrent sa tête
quand il revient regarder
[Musique]
plusieurs spécialistes dont redmond ont
déclaré que jamais un joueur de go
professionnelle devrait jouer un coup
pareil et pourtant ça a donné la
victoire à halle fargo dont je pense
qu'on peut véritablement dire qu'il
s'agit d'un 4 créativité de sa part
d'ailleurs depuis ce coup a été étudié
et enseigné par les joueurs de go qui
tente de comprendre comment exploiter ce
type de stratégie mais les choses ont
été encore plus loin par la suite
[Musique]
malgré le caractère impressionnant
d'alpha go il reste que s'il n'y avait
pas eu les grands maîtres du goût pour
le nourrir de milliers de parties
l'algorithme n'aurait pas existé
la technique qui consiste pour un
algorithme à apprendre à faire quelque
chose à partir d'exemples sur une base
de données s'appelle l'apprentissage
superviser superviser parce que il y a
les données qui sont là pour montrer à
l'algorithme ce qu'on attend de lui
mais il existe un autre type de
technique l'apprentissage par
renforcement il s'agit de méthodes ou un
algorithme est entraînée par essai
erreur en faisant des tentatives
successives qui sont à chaque fois plus
ou moins récompensés dans le cas d'hugo
ça consiste simplement à fournir à
l'algorithme les règles du gauche juste
les règles rien d'autre et le laisser
s'entraîner en jouant contre lui même il
peut comme sajoo et des milliers de
parties mettront au point des stratégies
les tester et progresser au fur et à
mesure en voyant ce qui fonctionne le
mieux
c'est comme ça que les chercheurs de
deep man ont créé alpha 0 un programme
capable d'apprendre tout seul à jouer à
des jeux abstraits comme les échecs ou
legault sans aucune intervention humaine
à part évidemment le fait de fournir à
l'algorithme les règles du jeu alpha 0
s'est entraîné tout seul en jouant
contre lui même
140 millions de parties de go alors ça
lui a quand même pris deux semaines en
utilisant 5000 processeur et à l'issue
de cette période on l'a fait jouer
contre alpha gaulle algorithmes
précédent celui qui avait battu lycée
dole en apprenant sur une base de
données alpha 0 à jouer sans parti
contrat le fagot et il les a tous deux
gagné 100 à 0 donc l'algorithme qui a
appris à jouer tout seul en
apprentissage par renforcement a explosé
celui qui avait appris sur des exemples
en apprentissage superviser mais ça
n'est pas tout
alpha 0 a aussi pu apprendre d'autres
jeux abstraits aux échecs il a joué 44
millions de parties contre lui même et
ça lui a pris seulement de 9 heures et
on l'a ensuite opposé aux meilleurs
programmes d'échec du monde
et oui car je n'ai pas dit mais suite à
la victoire de deep blue sur kasparov
l'amélioration des programmes des
chèques a continué ces programmes ne
servent plus tellement pour affronter
des humains on sait d'avancé comment ça
se passerait et aucun joueur
professionnel n'a envie d'aller se faire
humilier publiquement par un algorithme
mais on continue d'organiser des
tournois entre les programmes et à les
faire progresser le meilleur programme
du monde à l'heure actuelle s'appelle
stockfisch et il est bien bien
meilleur que deep blue 1 même s'ils
fonctionnent en gros sur des principes
similaires dit mike a donc organisé des
matches entre stockfisch et la version
d'alpha 0 qui a appris tout seul à jouer
aux échecs sur les 1000 parties alpha 0
en a gagné 155 et stockfisch seulement 6
le reste étant des matches nuls
outre la supériorité d'alpha 0 ce qui
est assez fascinant c'est le nombre de
positions évalué par chacun des
algorithmes stockfisch en a évalué en
moyenne 60 millions par seconde
pas très différente dit blouin on est
toujours sur une stratégie assez
bourrine alpha 0 au contraire on a
évalué seulement 60 milles par seconde
c'est à dire mille fois moins en testant
à chaque fois mille fois moins d'options
alpha 0 arrive à faire beaucoup mieux
que stockfisch il choisit avec une
efficacité redoutable les branches de
l'arbre des possibilités qui souhaitent
explorer je me souviens qu'un jour j'ai
discuté avec un excellent joueur
d'échecs et je lui ai demandé quelle
était la différence entre lui sa façon
de réfléchir quand il joue et moi qui
essayent de prévoir toutes les
possibilités comme un gros bois
m'expliquer en gros la chose suivante
moi quand je joue je regarde tous les
coups possibles mais ne regarde pas les
cookies sont interdits par les règles du
genre sauter des pièces avec ma tour ou
la déplacer en diagonale ces coups
interdits n'arrive même pas dans mon
champ de conscience pour être examiné eh
bien il m'a dit que lui c'était la même
chose mais avec les mauvais coups il les
voit même pas et donc son cerveau ne
perd pas de temps à les considérer à
calculer ou ça le mènerait tous les
mauvais coups que moi j'examinerai
patiemment ils n'atteignent même pas son
champ de conscience est bien face 0
c'est pareil
sa force n'est pas de calculs et
bourrine mans mais de choisir avec une
efficacité incroyable les options sur
lesquelles il va se concentrer
alors évidemment là aussi on peut se
demander est-ce qu alpha 0 fait preuve
de créativité et bien quand les
spécialistes regarde sa façon de jouer
il semble que ce soit clairement le cas
un premier point c'est khalfa 0 a
redécouvert lui même toutes les
ouvertures classique des échecs pour les
spécialistes
apparemment ses préférés c'est le
gambiste dames et l'ouverture anglaise
mais en cours de partie et son style est
parfois assez différent de ce que font
les humains ou les autres programmes
d'échec d'ailleurs notamment dans sa
manière d'évaluer les positions je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure de l'évaluation
qu'on apprend quand on débute aux échecs
9 points pour la dame 5 points pour la
tour et c'est parfois au cours du jeu
les humains font des sacrifices
c'est à dire des coûts qui leur font
perdre des points selon ce calcul mais
uniquement de façon très mesurée et
parce que ça va leur donner un super
avantage dans la position où la mobilité
est bien alpha 0 fait ça aussi mais de
façon beaucoup plus agressive
il fait les sacrifices qui semble
complètement fou il attribue plus de
valeur à la position et à la mobilité de
ses pièces que ne le ferait un joueur
humain et ça marche
je suis pas assez fort aux échecs pour
vous commenter ça de façon éclairée 1
mais on trouve sur youtube plusieurs
analystes deux parties entre alpha 0 et
stockfisch en voici une qui est
intéressante
alpha 0 à les blancs et stockfisch les
noirs et alpha 0 vient de faire
plusieurs sacrifices donc une tour pour
simplement pouvoir capturer un cavalier
regardez le compte des points à ce stade
de la partie
alpha 0 en blanc à quatre pions un fou
une tour et la dame
ça fait 21 points et stockfisch en noir
scipion deux tours et la dame 25 points
normalement avec une telle différence
les noirs devrait avoir partie gagnée
mais les sacrifices d'alpha 0 était
parfaitement mesuré et il s'est donné
une grande liberté de mouvement tout en
enfermant stockfisch quelques coups plus
tard la partie en est là et stockfisch
est complètement coincé et finit par
abandonner
et on trouve plusieurs autres exemples
de ces coups incroyables joué par alpha
0 qui a vraiment inventé sa propre façon
de jouer aux échecs différente de celle
des humains et des autres programmes
d'échec une vraie preuve de créativité
si vous avez du mal à vous représenter
ses prouesses créatif d'alpha 0 je vais
vous montrer un exemple un peu plus
ancien mais qui est très parlant avant
de s'attaquer aux goûts et aux échecs
dit manning avait étudié comment un
algorithme d'apprentissage par
renforcement pouvez apprendre à jouer
tout seul au jeu de la console atari
2600 à pour ceux qui n'ont pas connu
cette époque c'est le genre de jeu qu'on
voit dans ready player one un de ses
jeux ses breaks out le tout premier jeu
de casse-briques dit man a donné ce jeu
un algorithme d'apprentissage par
renforcement baptisé dès qu elle et
voici comment le style 2d qu elle a
évolué au cours de ces partis
d'apprentissage au bout de 100 périodes
d'entraînement l'algorithme a en gros
compris les grands principes mais il
continue de rater la balle assez
fréquemment
il faut attendre 400 période
d'entraînement pour qu'ils maîtrisent
parfaitement le jeu et rattrape
systématiquement la balle
mais si on continue à le faire jouer et
s'entraîner observez ce qui se passe
l'algorithme a acquis une telle maîtrise
qu'il a compris comment envoyer la balle
dans une direction donnée et il se
focalise sur les bords de façon à
pouvoir glisser la balle derrière le mur
et que le travail se fasse tout seul
c'est brillant non alors évidemment le
jeu n'est pas le seul domaine qui
permettent de mettre en évidence la
créativité des nouvelles formes
d'intelligence artificielle notamment
celle basée sur l'apprentissage par
renforcement et les techniques de deep
learning
j'aurais pu par exemple également vous
parler de création artistique mais
promis ce sera pour une prochaine fois
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo ça faisait
vraiment longtemps que j'en avais pas
fait donc n'hésitez pas à la partager à
la ligue et tout ça histoire de m'aider
à me faire pardonner par l'algorithme de
youtube
et puis comme d'habitude si vous voulez
plus de complément il y en a sur le blog
dans un billet dédié à bientôt
[Musique]